adolf hitler got his start in the
military during world war
one he's a dispatch runner on the
western front he actually gets fairly
decorated and by most accounts this is
where he finds
meaning he finds meaning in being part
of the military he finds
meaning in frankly the war itself but
then in 1918 we of course have the end
of the war well first you have
the the the abdication of the kaiser
you have republican government people
who want to form a republic
take control and then they sign an
armistice with the allies
in november and this is not well
received by hitler and frankly it's not
well received by many in
the military from their point of view
they somewhat delusionally believed
that the that germany would have won
world war one if they weren't stabbed in
the back by these november criminals by
the folks who had taken over
after the after the kaiser so you have
this whole stab in the back theory
stab in the back by those who had taken
over and signed the armistice and this
wasn't just believed by folks like
hitler
this was believed even by very senior
people in the military this right over
here is general ludendorff one of
two two people the other gentleman
hindenburg who were in charge of the
entire
german military he believed in the stab
in the back theory he thought that they
would have won
if they didn't sign the armistice if
these november criminals these people
who had taken control of the government
did not sign this with the allies
and then you go to 1919 from the point
of view of people like hitler things
only got worse you have the treaty of
versailles that applied all the war
guilt to the germans you have
these huge reparations that would even
be paid in resources
you have the former german empire
significant amount of its territory
is given over to to to the allies or to
form
new states then you also have the
the establishment of the the formal
establishment of the weimar
republic it's called the ymar republic
because the new german constitution
is drafted in the town of is drafted in
the town of weimar
and it sets it up as a parliamentary
democracy
that's why we now call it that's why
it's called a republic but it's a little
bit of bizarre of a parliamentary
democracy it actually gave a good bit of
power a directly elected president that
had a reasonable amount of power
especially in emergencies
and that would become relevant later on
when hitler actually comes to power
over a decade later but then in
1919 hitler was still looking you know
he was very upset about the war ending
he stays part of the military and part
of the military he's assigned to start
infiltrating or spying on the german
workers party
so spy on and the acronym
in german is the dap but the english
translation would be the german workers
party
but he actually gets quite impressed by
the german words by
the germans the german workers party
which is really
ultra nationalist and when we talk about
ultra-nationalist it's all about
german race superiority it's
it's it's in line with this whole idea
that they would have
won the war if they weren't stabbed in
the back
and it's also anti-communist
anti-communist it's anti-capitalist
and it's anti-ethnic minorities in
particular anti-jewish
anti-jewish and all of these ideas
hitler found very impressive
and just to be clear you know a lot of
times when people talk about
ultra-nationalist groups they associ
they often will call them
as ultra right wing ultra
right wing and this bears some
clarification because the right wing is
also
often con viewed as very capitalist
but ultra nationalists really put the
nation
and kind of the the the race that they
view as indicative of the nation above
all other concerns so yes they were
anti-communist they were
anti-distribution of
of wealth you know communist believe in
no classes
as little private property as possible
the alt the
not the the german workers part didn't
believe in that they were anti-that but
they were also anti-unfettered
capitalism
especially capitalism that might get in
the way of the nation's
interests but he becomes very impressed
with them
and he actually joins he actually joins
as the 55th member so you can imagine
this is a very
as it this at this point is a very very
small
party but then we fast forward to 1920
by 1920 the party leadership has taken
note of hitler
they find that he they actually notice
him when he's arguing with people and
that other people are listening he's
actually a really
great orator and so they allow him to
give more and more talks he has more and
more authority
and in order for the party to have more
of an appeal especially to nationalists
in general
they change their name they add to
german workers party they add the
nationalist socialist
german workers party dap german workers
party or the nsd
ap and if you pronounce nationalist in
german it sounds something like and i'm
going to butcher it right now
naturalists not synonymous and so if you
were to shorten it
they call themselves the nazis they call
themselves the nazis
and hitler actually designed the logo
for the nazis which
in which included this symbol right over
here the swastika
and the swastika is worth talking about
because it was really this bizarre
corruption of a very ancient symbol
the the hitler and the nazis created
this entire mythology around
the germans being the descendants of the
aryans or being the purest example of
the aryans that the aryans are the
the superior race that's responsible for
all of civilization's advancement
it was a delusion because frankly there
was an ancient aryan race
but the the best the the most indicative
descendants of them are frankly the
persians or the indians
and actually the swastika symbol here
you might actually even see it as a
hindu temple
it does not mean all of what we
associate with nazism now
it actually is an ancient hindu symbol
of auspiciousness
of good luck but the nazis usurped it
but for them this was a very important
idea to create this
this this mythology around race
superiority and to even have a symbol
like this as opposed to say something
like a cross that's a religious symbol
anyone can
have a belief could believe and say
christianity and and say hey i'm a
christian but the swastika at least in
hitler's mind in the nazis mind
was a racial symbol so it's it
represented it
represented their superior race and
obviously
if their race was superior a lot of what
they call what they consider the ills
of of germany were caused by by
by being infiltrated with what they
considered less pure races like
jews and also infiltrated with less pure
ideas like like the ideas
of communism but hitler gets more and
more recognition with the party the
party membership continues
to grow and by 1921
you have a a you have some disagreements
in the party some people threaten to
splinter off
and when when hitler says hey look if
this is gonna happen
i'm gonna i'm gonna leave the party they
realize that he has so much value to the
party that the party would just dissolve
if hitler leaves
and so they make him the chairman hitler
takes control
hitler is the chairman of the nazi party
chairman and by this point hitler is
well known on
or he becomes he's becoming more and
more well-known on the speaking circuit
and we now have several thousand members
of
the nazi party although it's still a
fairly small group
but then things start to get a lot worse
in weimar germany you start having
hyperinflation
you start having hyperinflation the
government
keeps printing more and more currency
a lot a lot of it in order the economy
is weak it's trying to pay reparations
and so what you have here this is
actually one of the most famous cases of
hyperinflation in world history
you see the value of their currency it
devalues from
1919 to 1923 not by a factor of a
thousand or a million or a billion but
nearly
a trillion so the the the currency
becomes frankly worthless then in 1922
or this is all the hyperinflation is
happening this entire time and you see
it accelerates through 1922 and then
but then in 1922 you have mussolini
comes to power in italy
and he comes to power through his march
on march on rome
and mussolini is a fascist that's where
the word comes from he's a member of the
fascist
party and i the fascists ideas were very
similar to the nazis it was all about
extreme nationalism all about racial
superiority a very strong
government and this is hitler finds
quite inspiring you have
the the the weimar republic is having
difficulty economic difficulty you have
many other groups including the
communists attempt their own
coup d'etats they fail but things are
getting less and less
stable then you fast forward to 1923
the inflation is getting super bad about
as bad as inflation can get the currency
is worthless
the economy is going in a tail spill
going into a tail spin
and on top of that because germany can't
pay the reparations to france anymore
france occupies the roar so the rural
region is occupied
occupied by france and you might
remember from the terms of the treaty of
versailles
the tsar region was already being
occupied and all that coal was being
shipped out to france
the rura region was another significant
region of coal and steel production
and now the french are fully occupying
this they're forcing a lot of the
civilians out of the region they're
forcing a lot of the workers to work in
the
in the in the mines and the and the and
the factories
and then they're shipping all of that
supply out to france
so this adds further it further
debilitates the economy but it's a huge
humiliation the treaty of versailles
and the minds of germans especially in
the minds of nationalists was
bad enough but now you have this huge
humiliation
by the french and this isn't just
amongst the nationalists the the general
german population is getting
very very very very upset about this and
so this gives a lot of fuel to extreme
nationalist groups like the nazis so
this fuels
the nazis and based on the estimates
i've seen entering into the year they're
starting to have
in excess of 10 000 members starting to
be several tens of thousands and by
we as we get into the later part of the
year we're approaching i've seen
estimates of forty thousand
forty thousand to fifty five thousand
members of the nazi party that's just
formal members
and then on top of that you might have
non-members who are growing
increasingly sympathetic and so what
we'll see in the next video at the end
of 1923
hitler sees this as his chance he's
inspired by mussolini
the economy is in a tailspin the the
germans have been further humiliated by
the french
and they're starting to get quite the
nazis in particular are starting to get
quite popular